everything they do is so high quality
and so so good oh my gosh yeah this is
like shallow and basketball yes
yo that was cool though
today's episode is brought to you by
Squarespace stick around to the end to
see how you can get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh we have some great clips for
you today there's some deep Dives
there's some great clips there's some
bad Clips there's everything in between
and I'm really excited to share we're
here today for much anticipated episode
mostly for me I was anticipating this
episode because the last time we tried
to do a Bollywood one well our warm-up
clip ended up taking over the entire
episode and that's our react video to
saho which is a great film go watch it
but you got more Clips this time yes
because yeah you know I didn't come to
that episode with just goops I actually
did some research and I had a couple
other things and I had some fun facts
and well today we finally get to do it I
stealed my mind so that I don't get
driven and say in a second time
so there's this actor named horrific
Roshan and he's one of the highest paid
actors in Indian Cinema we're talking
about multi-million dollar deals for
these films and it is nuts one of the
most famous pictures he's in is a series
called Chris let's watch a clip from
Chris three it's a very famous scene to
get ourselves re-familiarized with where
we're heading right where we're heading
yeah
I know where this is going so obviously
there's a problem with the plane
someone's gonna have to save the day oh
what
oh I remember this dude yeah
wow
yeah very fast and he flies through the
sky dude Neo POV did all these CG
buildings though it's uh pretty solid
what's interesting about this shot here
so the buildings that you see in the
foreground are all 3D but right behind
that's all just like a matte painting in
the background there's not any depth to
it those are not 3D buildings it's all
just a photo that is tracked into the
scene and it's far enough away that
you're not going to get the Parallax
that shows that it's just a flat image
and then a green screen element of him
jumping down and Landing vibrating with
energy I feel like Indian VFX took
basically what VFX were in 2008 and then
perfected all those techniques and like
when you're getting into YouTube like
what the VFX we're doing like Indian
Cinema is that perfect
they ran out of the render but they
still had to keep the shot going so they
just freezed it on the last frame yeah
oh yeah what up this is how to get
faster I'm gonna go so fast
yeah you would be missed would be missed
and I do straining apparently
oh getting crushed in the landing gear
did it oh they got a camera we good
yeah we good
look at this he's like all right time to
shine no going back this is a dude on
the front of the airplane yeah they just
2D track them
I mean that was a bit of a 3D track
there there's Parallax he is the
suspension system
wait I thought I thought jump
but this is that's the magic of
Bollywood you know
oh snap do you think like Indian actors
like this are like aware of how fun and
perhaps goofy their pieces are like do
you think they take themselves really
seriously or do you think they're like
nah man this is just entertainment we're
out here to have a good time and make
people laugh but I hope it's the latter
me too because I mean it's working I'm
having a great time I think what
happened here is Indian Cinema just
leaped over American Cinema and they
just adapted to anime into live action
before we did we've talked about that
before Hollywood is essentially just
Anime IRL yeah it's not about looking
real it's about being fun and conveying
funny ideas and while looking as cool as
you possible those dust shots are cool
like I'm down it's comparable to matrix
resurrections
it's comparable I'm not saying it's
better or worse so let's turn back the
clock here so we're gonna go on a little
deep dive exploration on the Chris
Series so we just watched the clip from
Chris three so we're gonna go back one
movie and watch Chris wait wait one
movie Yes it goes Chris three and then
you go back to the movie before called
Chris what happened to Chris too
wait Chris two I believe doesn't exist
so there's actually a film before Chris
called koi Mel Gaia
and I think as they were making the
films they renamed the second one to
Krish and then when after that came out
they're like should we call it Chris too
and they're like well it's technically
the third movie so it's Chris three now
and so like okay okay I see that logic
so do you think he's into cosplay and he
had made the mask himself I think we're
watching like Steve Vai as a superhero
who's that guy yeah he's evil that's who
he is his identity
whoa that was cool that's a cool shot
yeah that's a real shot there yeah it
looks like it's a dope shot that's cool
and the camera guy got to do this done
too yeah the camera
it's like oh is he gonna stand on the
fountain to get a super boost
yes
wow color grading there's always power
windows happening power windows only
like isolate a little spot to like
brighten it and if you look you see it's
like a really bright circle around him
like at all times here in the close-up
here
need more feather
this is a very convoluted way to chase a
helicopter now he's swimming
[Applause]
[Music]
who are these guys who are they in trees
so here we go now we're getting like
full anime here get off our Island we'll
beat him with machete this is like a
side quest because I don't think they
have anything to do with the main bad
guy they just they're just like
inhabitants of the small island what are
you doing oh look at those CG trees they
don't look too bad oh my gosh
is so it's so intense
this is pure anime this is 100 anime
right here now it's just like four it's
just a full anime commitment I love it
cool interesting technique on the blurry
background so you just take the camera
and whip it around and that's your
footage
like it's changing geometry yeah a
little more planning would have been
cool
then it ends with that shot I mean
that's a dope shot
so he's in the boss's Lair all right and
this is it he's oh there's doves
oh no wait what is this dumpy dude gonna
do hi I'm just a normal 50 year old man
fighting you and I have a gun all right
so question of the day who is that
Indian Al Pacino no who's the person in
the wheelchairs twin brother yeah no
it's his father oh papa is it just the
same actor yeah it's the same actor
father father oh that's cool that's a
cool split shot that's smart so all
they're doing is the head and torso is
just a separate layer on the left yeah
okay and the hand is someone else's hand
yeah actually I didn't even notice that
shot but that's like it's super clever
and really convincing yeah Bravo hey
whoa
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa there yo that was cool though that
shot is definitely backwards and they
reversed it wait really yeah watch his
hair oh my God you're right
here we go dude look at
those wait wait wait wait wait time out
so fast
wait did he shoot twice or was it one
shot he shot twice one shot that they're
both in the air at the same time
he goes like bang bang and then but
they're still like perfectly light all
right you know how he gets out of this
right you know how he saves him right I
think he's going to take that fire
extinguisher and hit one bullet and take
the other okay interesting I'm gonna
make two guesses I know it's cheating
make two guesses guest number one is he
hits one bullet into the other bullet oh
my God that's a knockout of the way
guess number two is more convoluted he
grabs the bad guy he picks him up he
throws them in front of the bullets and
he has the bad guy take both shots
all right let's find out here we go he's
got to go oh that's crazy there it is
you can hit the one bullet oh come on oh
yeah straight up just straight up Matrix
triples oh
obviously blocked the bullet and took a
bullet yeah all right Bravo Ren you
called it he's not holding that it's a
CG fire extinguisher the whole time he's
just running and they cg'd his fingers
in to make it look like he was holding
it do you think they filmed that plate
of him flying it's just standing up
probably look at his hair yeah he's just
standing up
yeah I think yeah look at his feet he's
just standing up on a green screen oh
hello Scrappy Indian Cinema is it like
it really makes him feel approachable
like I can do it I can go out there and
I can make movies and it's true you can
go out there and make movies
punch you into another dimension oh
right through him he ripped the back of
his suit he punched him so hard haul
right into the computer oh wait they
filmed that in two separate shots yeah
there's like a plate of glass shattering
and then a plate of him hitting the
ground because it's not a stunt double
punk in the ground there it's like the
actual actor I feel like there's a
commitment to physicality in Indian
Cinema we're like if you're an actor you
have to like be physical and do some of
the cool stuff that your character is
doing I always appreciate that so yeah I
know the questions you're asking like
this father character what's going on
yeah and that computer this old computer
the star what's this magic star well
like okay how do you think he got a
superpowers
and one night a spaceship descended on
their town oh wow some aliens
[Laughter]
um
the layers so basically the Alien made
his father smart again He restored his
IQ and then he gave him supernatural
abilities and then when Jadu left he
lost his IQ points but retained the
Superhuman physical abilities and so
when he was born he got all the best
that he got the best of the best
anyway so that's the flashback scene so
that's a great segue let's watch Cornell
guy a little bit which is technically
Chris one but it's a different movie
completely if what we're watching right
now is like a Marvel movie koi mil Gaya
is like an 80s Steven Spielberg kids
movie it is insane how they managed to
transition the story from one genre film
to a completely different one
that's the point of the show the thing
is like you'll be like why is it a
basketball game which is a full team of
adults versus one adult and then a bunch
of children I don't exactly know that
answer but I do know that the reason
he's playing with the children is
because he is mentally a child but the
thing is is that he's met Jadoo by this
point so not only has superhuman
abilities but he has the IQ of the
adults
[Music]
oh he just dunked so high on that basket
so he's doing well yeah see see that's
the pivotal plot point we can't jump any
higher we're too young he's like you do
I really could use a hand
wait is Jadoo a sack are they gonna
realize that this like random burlap
sack that's sitting on the court is like
an alien is this an alien or like a bomb
or what's going on Jenny gets his energy
from the sunlight if we put the alien in
the bag how can we harness his magic
powers everybody's like hmm Lord Krishna
please do something apparently Krishna
still exists in the universe of the
aliens wait it's not that he needs
direct sunlight it's just the bag needs
sun on it is his head solar panels yeah
oh you're right oh yeah here we go these
wires are so fun
oh my gosh yeah this is like shallow and
basketball yeah this is great
[Music]
I thought you're closer you just line
drives it
it's a fun day on set yeah yeah that
looks like a blast so this is like the
foundation for how he's able to save
airplanes
how his son saves there eventually yeah
it gets powerful enough to save
airplanes
foreign so the cops are chasing to do
and the father guess what it's not the
aliens it's the rag tag kids haha
where's Jadoo you're not gonna find him
where is he
is that a Razor scooter
and this is the guy that was in the
wheelchair in The Last Action yeah you
just watched yeah this is the guy in the
wheel that does not look right hold up
that did not look right
why are his feet off of the scooter he's
like have fun
wait Loops back around this is the
ending shot of Crush three so it Loops
all the way back around to this movie
Yes this shot of him
oh my gosh yes we do it home little
buddy
we're saving him
[Laughter]
well oh yeah
give him a big kiss oh the Reflections
in the eye see there's not a Bollywood
movie without composited eye Reflections
that stick to the eyes as they move
but they got the Reflections in there
they did the job yeah it's hard to
really talk about the effects in this
film because it's more just like the
context that supports these other
massive superhero flicks that are coming
out is really I think what makes it
interesting but what a genre shift from
like what we watched there with Chris 3
of like this like Marvel like superhero
stuff to like these like wholesome like
E.T Origins uh so we should watch the
trailer for Krish fourth Krish four is
it out no but the trailer's out and you
watch it and you're like so this is why
it was great to go backwards to the
original and now watch this and go so
those children and the scooter and all
that stuff led to this
thank you
wait Universal Fox Studio
well I think that's just the made-up
name
after eight years
yeah yeah
dude look how crazy this looks now right
you're like what whoa whoa right
yeah that was a lost in spaceship oh am
I fake did I get
pranked that is the Lost in Space robot
okay
we got pranked we got pranked by a fan
trailer Universal Fox Studios is too
good to be true man we got so hyped
there for a moment man dude they just
got me oh no God dang it foreign
means don't forget to subscribe I saw
you there I saw you there almost
forgetting
I was like I'm about to click oh whoops
this next film is called fan it's got
Shahrukh Khan in it he likes to use
visual effects to alter his appearance
he was the small guy he was the small
guy exactly and we saw that there was a
lot of advanced stuff happening there
yeah and this movie was the precursor to
that where they first started
experimenting with how far they could go
with digitally altering his appearance
so this is him his face changed so this
is the nerdy young version of him young
Khan and everything we're watching here
even the most minute details of this
performance are being altered whoever's
doing effects work on this guy's movies
he's nailing it it's our boys Red Hot
Chili of course knew it love it
everything they do is so high quality
and so so good wow look that's crazy
yeah right it's it's really really well
done how do you think they do this type
of like de-aging they're probably doing
a 3D track of his face with a face mesh
and they're taking the image and
basically projection mapping it onto
that mesh which then gives them
something static that they can paint and
touch and alter basically to remove
blemishes on the skin and things like
that and since it's tracked to them it's
just there naturally we actually talked
about this in our episodes Joe Farrell
uh he did a great job explaining it so
go check out that episode if you haven't
seen it but I also think there's a
little bit of warping and shaping going
on similar to how they did Chris Evans
and Captain America and they made him
skinny not obviously that extreme but I
think they're doing a little face
warping around well they do that every
time they de-age an actor for those
Marvel movies too you know where it's
like you have older actors now playing
their younger self and it's more than
just painting out wrinkles and whatnot
you have to like literally tighten up
the face yeah because the face sags as
you get older ears and noses like you
growing or something like that so you
gotta like shrink all that but do that
proportionately correct it's not just
like shrinking it uniformly it helps
after just doing a little bit of weird
warping so you don't have to like
convince you it's a different person
it's just like it has to feel just a
little different in a weird subtle way
you can really tell what the nose shape
they like really tighten up the younger
version's nose do red chilies have a
breakdown of any effects yes they do
have a breakdown on these effects okay
so they're doing the face shape with
makeup that's smart that way you're not
sitting there trying to warp his face
shape all the time you just you got to
make up doing the face shape and you can
just see the texture work later on in
post wait hold up wait hold up they
painted up
wait
patterns in lines to track you have to
get right to shrink his size look at
that oh my gosh you see that they moved
the dad in wow I know the move it's like
full George Lucas like redoing shot
composition this is horrifying this is
like scary how much work this is I yeah
and then the pain out around his
shoulders yeah I saw some questions in
the last VFX I was reacting what do you
mean by painting in you didn't explain
it all right painting it is basically
you move something and it leaves a hole
in your shot imagine cutting something
out with scissors and you need to like
patch that hole with parts of your image
when it needs to move that gets more
complicated when the things that you're
filling in the holes with are people
that are actively moving how are you
feeling in those holes the sheer fabric
like when it's got Wiggles and wrinkles
and light coming through and stuff
behind it moving and they're like
patching that in somehow it's crazy
isn't that's crazy yeah it is Flawless
and the fact that you're watching in
motion you can't see the patchwork I
mean I'm willing to bet they probably
got some clean a good amount of clean
plates for all these shots it doesn't
change anything it makes it still so
hard the first easiest way to paint
something out is to use what's called a
Clean Plate where you actually have your
actor get out of the shot so you can
actually see the clean environment
behind what you're going to try to cut
out and then you can just take that and
then fill it in once you do cut the
person out yeah but the problem is clean
plates are only useful up to the point
where something in the background starts
moving let's say you have a person
standing behind your actor how do you
get a clean play to that actor well you
could maybe just film an entire take and
rotoscope your actor and just slap them
on top of it all but we're seeing scenes
here like him in the crowd there when
they shrink him down he's actually
standing there in the crowd of those
people that's not a Clean Plate
situation here you have to basically
rebuild using what like clone tools and
tracking and
it was it was the exact thing I did to
rebuild my leg and our first boss Town
video
he steps behind the reflective glass so
we're talking about clean plates as if
they're behind someone what if there is
something that goes in front of them
like a reflective window it looks like
they had to rebuild that entire section
of the store from plates remove the
reflections apply the effects and then
slap artificial Reflections back on yeah
you can see how they removed the
reflection there yeah the super bright
in the left and now it's dim on the
right maybe it's because you can see the
crew is that the crew there's definitely
some people watching it kind of looks
like either a crowd watching the scene
or the crew cool well yeah there's a lot
of great stuff in this film I'm a fan
I'm a fan
okay one thing I love about Indian
Cinema is just how the characters can
achieve almost anything they set their
minds to you know all the rules about
the confines of real life they're gone
and courtesy of today's sponsor
Squarespace you can do anything you set
your mind to this year all you need is a
beautiful website and Squarespace it's
gonna allow you to build that website
without knowing anything about web
design maybe you've got your own small
business maybe you've got a service
maybe you've got a product and you want
to get those ideas out into the world
well you are going to need a website and
Squarespace offers you beautiful
award-winning templates with 24 7
customer service that allows you to
build out and customize your website
just for you now Squarespace has a bunch
of great tools and we've been using them
for years one of my favorites is the
multiple contributors tool this allows
you to give different people different
levels of access to your Squarespace
website which allows everyone to
contribute something different without
having to use the same login which is
kind kind of awkward they've also got a
members area feature which allows you to
section off and give exclusive content
to just members of your website that's a
really useful tool especially when it
comes to today's day and age and the
subscription models that we've seen so
often and of course Squarespace allows
you to embed videos embed audio maybe
you have a podcast or you're on a show
you want to make sure that's featured on
your website Squarespace is going to
allow you to do that they also have some
of the best traffic overviews tools in
the game which allow you to understand
how people come to your website how they
utilize it and then allow you to better
craft your website based on people's
experiences so anyways guys huge thanks
to Squarespace they've been a sponsor of
this show for years they've got a great
tool and it's going to allow you to do
something that you might not think is
possible just like Indian Cinema if you
guys are interested in getting started
for yourself head on over to
squarespace.com Corridor crew and you
get 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain that's squarespace.com
quarter crew for 10 off your first
purchase of a website foreign anyways
wow huge thanks to them let's get back
to this craziness
so I haven't seen a lot of Indian Cinema
but I'm sure some of you have so I want
to see some of the crazy scenes from the
last few years of Cinema history here
from India so we're relying on all of
you out there who are watching Indian
Cinema to help fill in the gaps for us
because uh there's a lot of content to
get through
yeah I mean I know I look at the
comments to try to get ideas for what we
should look at next so all of you Indian
Cinema enjoyers out there help us out
thank you
enjoyers enjoyers
foreign
yeah that was amazing that was so much
fun I had no idea the Chris Cinematic
Universe was so large and I hope it just
continues thank you so much for watching
we got more of these in the works see
you next week